which is emergency medical services and
our Virginia Beach Sheriff's Office
deputies to a report of shots being
fired in building two within two minutes
the first officers arrived on scene now
when I say on scene that's outside the
building and we have to remember this
building is four floors it has a
basement and three stories has numerous
entrances numerous exits and they are
different because citizens cannot enter
certain areas and there because they are
secured
there are numerous stairwells in this
building there's a basement in the
building the basement goes to a tunnel
which connects to another building so
this this is not like being in the
confines of this sterile environment
where we are right now this is a huge
building and we had no idea where the
suspect was we have no idea what the
extent of the the shots being fired call
really included but they were there
within two minutes the other thing I
need to say is that the building was
originally constructed in the early
1970s when the city had a much smaller
workforce since that time and as
construction has gone on for decades
offices have been subdivided entrances
and exits to certain offices it's a
honeycomb that's the best way to explain
it it's a maze where the workers are
where the citizens come in is very is
very well controlled but those offices
especially the further into the building
you get becomes extremely difficult to
navigate just because it's an older
building and it's been reconstructed
numerous times and no we did not have
plans to the building and we weren't in
a place to be able to make those review
plans we were moving at a rapid pace
between 415 and 418 and I have to give a
little bit of time on that because
officers call things in but please
remember they're not calling things in
one
exactly happening because sometimes they
have other issues to deal with like
where's the suspect what kind of gun is
he carrying interviewing people to be
able to find the suspect
there's myriad things happening at that
moment in time and it is extremely
chaotic so between 415 and 418 for five
to eight minutes after these officers
began to enter the building to make
contact and engage that the suspect on
the second floor of the building now I I
want to pause here for a moment because
while they were in that process other
police officers were responding and they
were also making entry into the building
searching in other areas I also have to
accentuate the fact that these four
officers did not work together they
worked in different commands however for
years and years of training in our city
and our Police Agency in the cross
training that we do with our partners in
the Sheriff's Department in our fire
department and our EMS department we
cross train and we train together on the
same tactics so therefore these four
officers who came from different
commands to or from the detective bureau
which is about i said the other day
about a hundred yards 150 we measured it
it's actually three hundred yards away
from door to door they responded from
the detective bureau to other officers
who were k9 officers responded via their
vehicles in rally so they came from
different commands yet they formed rapid
entry team and they entered the building
the family suspect on the second floor
and immediately gained engaged in a gun
battle i've been asked on a couple of
occasions how long i can't tell you how
many minutes shots were being fired i
could tell you that in the police world
anything more than three to five shots
is a long gun battle that's what was
happening i can tell you that although i
do not have the exact number of rounds
that the perpetrator fired it was well
into the double digits
as this the suspect was firing he was
moving remember we had numerous office
spaces and the office spaces were
connected and then you would go into
another space and it's not connected
remember doors were closed and were
locked because individuals who were
still on that floor were sheltering in
place and doing exactly what everyone in
the country is trained to do on an
active shooter case that's another
sidebar folks we now have to train
across America on active shooter cases
they immediately are they were returning
fire and at one point the suspect was
firing through the door and through the
wall at the officers and then the firing
stopped they realized he was he was a
distance from them he was in another
office they realized the need to enter
that office so so that he would not then
escape and perpetrate more violence on
that second floor so they had to figure
a way to breach the door and a
tactically safe and sound way that's not
an easy decision to make there's an
individual on the other side of the door
he has a gun he just shot one of your
officers that officer was was wounded at
about 419 do now we have to breach the
door they had to come up with a plan to
do that
gunfire inside the door and when they
breached the door suspect was then alive
and was taken into custody and first aid
was immediately rendered to him it has
to be noted while these original
officers were doing this the rest of the
building was being secured remember we
always tactically respond to the thought
of numerous suspects
so other officers were going through the
building and basically assisting our
employees and getting out of the
building in a safe and secure manner
while our officers were engaged in this
we're removing individuals who were
wounded and moving individuals who were
injured firing an EMS personnel were on
scene we and we reacted in what we call
a tactical rescue rescue rescue task
force I apologize in that Fire and
Rescue personnel at times were embedded
with the police to actually move down a
hallway and find individuals to get them
out of the building so in summing up
some of this want you to know that the
total time from arrival of contact is
between five and eight minutes the total
time that it took to take the individual
into custody around their first day to
get him out of the building was 36
minutes the first critical transport 25
minutes from the time
there's a lot that goes on in finding an
individual who's injured and getting
them to an ambulance and rendering the
aid that they need at the ambulance
yes
injured individuals transported within
an hour of the original call going
also wanted to mention that during this
entire time 9-1-1 dispatchers control of
the radio of which was extremely chaotic
especially with extremely busy extremely
intense especially with a number of
other city agencies responding to the
scene so that's the best timing that I
can give you right now we've interviewed
the officers we've gone through our
computer dispatch system we are
interviewing firefighters rescue
personnel Sheriff's Department personnel
as well as other city workers who are in
the building at the time I will ask the
city manager come back to the forum ng
all right somebody left the phone up
here alright so let me let me repeat
what the chief just told you we have an
open investigation that is just in its
third day this includes establishing a
motive to the extent that the subjects
employment status has anything to do
with these events that will be part of
the ongoing investigation however he was
not terminated and he was not in the
process of being terminated so where are
we and where are we going I've made a
determination that we will be closing
the city offices of our municipal center
on Monday this will include the
treasurer's office in the commissioner's
office which is inside building one
schools and courts will operate along
with all other city offices around the
city on their normal schedule there may
be under these modified conditions a
requirement for essential personnel
associated with that clothed with those
closed offices to come in and assist us
in the relocation effort that will be
underway
on Tuesday we expect to open up all the
municipal center city offices to include
the treasurer and the Commissioner's
Office except for building two that will
be closed until further notice a
significant amount of relocation effort
planning and and movement of office
technology files and associated
furniture necessary to to relocate those
functions will be underway throughout
this week and into the following week so
that we can figure out a way to continue
providing services to our citizens our
businesses and our visitors there will
be significant memorial services
scheduled both internal for our staff as
well as external for families and
friends and I appreciate everybody who
is stepping up to help sponsor those
those are being identified on our VB gov
website and we will continue to add to
that list I'm extremely pleased with the
effort ongoing with our family liaison
teams family liaison officers have been
appointed from our honor guards in the
police department and the fire
department along with chaplains and
leadership from departments and my
office we have reached out and contacted
all the victims families last night and
into this morning we are now extending
our liaison support to our to our
wounded to those that are in the
hospital and the families that are
supporting them and we will be wrapping
our arms around them as they
coming out of their surgeries because
all of them have had multiple surgeries
and they are progressing and our prayers
are with them these family liaison teams
are providing them information about
where their loved ones are how their
loved ones are being released from the
medical examiner how to move forward
with those important funeral decisions
we are wrapping arms around them about
their benefits about where we're going
to support them we are a point of
contact and we are making sure that they
know they are not alone
and that is our critical function at the
same time our Employee Assistance
Programs are are taking shape and
multiple teams from our sister cities
from our state agencies from our federal
agencies are pouring in to assist us as
we wrap our arms around our employees so
that they can come to grips with what
transpired all around them and so that
we can get our stuff together so that
we're able to resume normal lives and
resume our mission of supporting
services to our great city so I
appreciate you all being here and
covering this story but please
understand that there are a lot of
people that are not as open to
discussing family and personal matters
as as some others might be and so we are
still respecting the privacy and of our
families so at this time chief and I are
prepared to take questions
chief George teeth at this point of the
investigation we do not have that any of
the information that he was targeting
anyone specifically okay so as the
manager I have had a very thorough
review of the status of the perpetrator
I have to my knowledge the perpetrators
performance was satisfactory that he was
in good standing within his department
and that there were no issues of
discipline ongoing
we continue to look at that there are
significant interviews that you all are
conducting and out there we are not
sensing that and I have no evidence that
that is the case as a city employee what
we can track is it entering an exit of
certain doorways because because we have
our codes to do that so as part of the
investigation what we're going to do is
as best as we can put together his total
activities from the morning until he
perpetrated this crime words matter sir
we've spoken through I'm not putting
water on it I'm trying to give the facts
we're looking as deep as we can into
motives from work personal motives
professional motors motives that could
have happened right now we're in the
process of doing all this i right now we
do not have anything glaring there's
nothing that hits you right between the
eyes but we are working on it and I will
because we're on TV all over the region
if anyone has any information on this
particular individual on a motive on
past experiences with him let us know so
we could put it all together because
remember as the manager said we have a
large workforce and we want that large
workforce to be able to come to work and
and feel safety there's only so much
safety and security you're going to feel
immediately but just so they know
they're safe and secure in your working
body
one moment sir let's have some semblance
of order so I'm gonna finish because he
probably has a follow-up then I'll come
back to you sir the investigators our
team of detectives are out interviewing
everyone so if they have not immediately
all the family members been spoken to
they will as quick as we can get to
everyone this is a large-scale
investigation now sir they immediately
render first aid they extricated him
from the building and he was transported
to the hospital yes sir
but but again I want to accentuate the
fact that we rendered first aid at the
scene as we always do yes sir and I'm
glad you really picked up on that
because put yourself in that position
you just took numerous rounds one of
your fellow officers was just injured
was shot you you find the individual and
then you immediately switch over to I'm
going to try and save his life because
our police officers truly believe in a
sanctity of life sir thank you for
asking that question hand up first
they did not have body cameras we are in
the process of phasing in body cameras
across the department two of them would
not have had body cameras because
they're detectives so they would be one
of the last to get body cameras so the
answer to your question they did not
have body cams and we do not have any
access to any other video at this time
in the villain what one one now sir I'll
get to you
once again that was asked previously
we're doing the best we can to
reconstruct his entire day okay yes yes
he was not his immediate supervisor but
he was in the chain of command we are
determining where that letter is he
notified his chain of command that
morning yes
my understanding is he did that via
email negative
not to my knowledge the 36 minute time
align and let me refer back from time
and dispatch to time of suspect in
custody I cannot hear you sir no sir I
said time of dispatch to custody is 36
minutes
I do not with me at this time one minute
sir yes the ATF provided that yesterday
I don't know if they provided all the
information once that's relevant we will
get that information out yes sir I I'm
gonna have to defer to ATF and their
once one moment sir yes sir
yes sir
which is a long time I'll be right back
to you yes sir I cannot comment on that
at this time because I don't have all
the facts in front of me
again I'm gonna defer that until I have
all the facts in front of me from the
ATF by the way the ATF has been superb
in assisting in this particular
investigation they understand the
criticality of the information we need
we're going to take just a few more
questions so yes sir I do not have that
information at this time as a matter of
fact that I'll have to come from the
medical examiner's office as best as he
can reconstruct yes sir I I do not have
that exact information that's being
pieced together by the detectives
you
you find anything that you get any
specifics that's what sort of anything
rendered what sort of like the first
question I'm not going to release any
information as to what we found inside
the home and as far as the second one
goes I do not have specifics as to what
kind of first day they rendered are all
of our officers carry tourniquets we
also have certain pieces of equipment in
in the police cars I don't know we it's
commonly referred to as a go-bag I don't
know if they had those with them at the
time but I will certainly be able to
follow up on that all right appreciate
you all being here today thanks Council
as always